key bonjour mon intervention a pour
sujet l'art de pédaler dans la
choucroute sais mais je fais du métier
ce qu'ils sont c'est un réalisateur et
scénariste scénariste c'est ce qui prend
le plus de temps et c'est la classe de
pédaler dans la choucroute est très
utile ces deux métiers bon qui prête pas
à conséquence dansant se passait pas
comme sage femme médecin chirurgien
ingénieur nucléaire si le pire qui peut
arriver quand plus personne mais qu'on
fasse un mauvais film et que les gens
s'ennuient et ça les réalisateurs et ils
n'ont pas envie d'en manger pas envie
donc dû pédaler dans la choucroute est
un processus qui fait avancer les choses
souvent après un film en demande d'où
vient l'idée d'où vient l'inspiration et
là je sais jamais répondre à part je ne
sais pas parce que je ne sais pas la
plupart du temps j'ai pas beaucoup
d'idées les idées que j'ai ne tiennent
pas ensemble ne font pas tout dire un
tas de cailloux et en tant que
scénariste on passe beaucoup de temps à
pédaler dans la choucroute
quand j'étais jeune ça m'inquiétait je
me disais ah oui là je suis en train de
pédaler dans la choucroute est il
maintenant que j'ai 60 ans je suis
habitué je [ __ ] dans la choucroute
donc c'est la seule chose qui acquit à
qui a changé parce que le processus fait
le métier de scénariste ces êtres 90% du
temps incompétent et inconscient du
temps face à un scénario qui ne
fonctionne pas des scènes qui vont pas
ensemble deux des personnages qui sont
pas cohérents et et et c'est juste les
10 derniers % du temps la toute fin aux
10 à 1
là je suis scénariste compétent parce
que ça marche et la plupart du temps on
sait pas pourquoi ça marche donc dans
l'art de pédaler dans la choucroute
j'ai quelques méthodes que j'ai établi
au fil des années
la première s'asseoir trois heures par
jour écrire trois pages bonne ou
mauvaise j'avais un très bon professeur
de scénario qui disait la qualité d'un
scénariste se voit à l'usure des
pantalons ci s'est illustré ici au
niveau des fesses ça veut dire que c'est
un bon scénariste
le deuxième conseil s'est barré dans son
agenda trois pages par jour vous les
bars et si on vous téléphone que je
propose quelque chose dit non je sois
rendez vous et vous avez un rendez vous
avec vous même auquel vous êtes tenus
d'être en cas de panne réduire la taille
des papiers quand j'ai peu d'idées
j'essaye de travailler sur des fiches
très petites comme ça j'ai l'impression
que gestion plus vite remplie et puis
après avoir des tables qu'angers s'en
fiche de s'en fiche
à ce moment là je mets trois tables
qu'on pourrait appeler le début le
milieu la fin de traversée le premier
acte de semak le troisième acte et là je
les étals les abandonner l'histoire
finit par apparaître sans que j'ai à
travailler quelque part et à ce moment
là je j'augmente la taille du papier jeu
passant la 4g cris toute l'histoire du
début à la fin
quand j'écris toute l'histoire du début
à la fin je la remets en fiche et puis
je leur ai organise en limogeant en
mettant des agrafes
quand il ya des répétitions avec deux
personnages en faisant 1 5
l'essai
chose pour le lendemain pendant que je
suis en train d'écrire j'essaye de ne
pas finir tout à fait ce qui fait que le
lendemain quand je me remets dans mon
rendez vous avec moi même je sais par
quoi commence et ça m'évite là le début
de la page blanche avec le curseur qui
clignote là et 6 c'est si vous avez un
ami qui est scénariste aussi travailler
ensemble c'est pas mal parce que quand
vous passez une après midi sans avoir
une seule bonne idée
ben c'est une sale après midi alors que
si vous êtes à deux et que vous n'avez
pas eu une seule bonne idée au moins
vous avez passé une bonne après-midi
et puis un jour le scénario est terminé
il est fini je sais jamais si c'est
parce qu'il est bien aussi c'est parce
que j'en ai marre d'écrire je crois
qu'il ya vraiment un scénariste deux
qualités fondamentales c'est être
obstiné bien peu con un peu conseille de
ne pas si vous êtes un peu con vous
rendez pas compte que ça va être aussi
difficile
rendez pas compte que ça va être lent
que ça va encore vous allez devoir tout
réapprendre à 0 que ça va pas marcher
donc scénario président ça va pas
marcher dans celui ci et qui a aucune
des recettes qui marchent donc aussi d
un peu con ça aide
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]